pour mettre son bateau de pêche à l'eau
claude gagnon doit payer 300 $ par
saison à verchères à varennes
ces 600 dollars ici à repentigny 500
dollars donc vous comprendrez qu'un
pêcheur comme moi qui aime pêcher à
différents endroits
s'il faut j'en paye une ici à 500
dollars tapie dont un pour justifier ses
tarifs
les municipalités affirme qu'elle était
envahi par les non résidents
dominique l'on paie et directeur général
adjoint de la ville de repentigny plus
de 65 % des utilisateurs la rampe de
mise à l'eau étaient des non repentis le
tarif de 500 $ a atteint son but cette
année un seul non résidents utilisent ce
32 mise à l'eau mais selon cet expert
cette pratique des villes pourraient
être illégales on peut différencier au
niveau des tarifs entre les résidents et
non-résidents ça je n'ai pas de problème
avec ça mais on ne doit jamais le faire
au point où le but est d'empêcher des
gens d'utiliser d'avoir leur droit
public de navigation malgré cela de plus
en plus de municipalités utilisent les
tarifs pour bloquer l'accès aux pêcheurs
et aux plaisanciers une politique
inacceptable selon martin bourges et
animateur de l'émission loisirs chasse
et pêche sens et la discrimination qu'on
fait littéralement parce qu'on dit est
pauvre résidents de la place sur 1.6
interpellé par cette situation le
gouvernement du québec a décidé d'agir
moi je pense cette situation n'est pas
acceptable parce que les plans d'eau du
québec appartiennent à l'ensemble des
québécois c'est la pierre moreau le
ministre des affaires municipales
annonce que le gouvernement a
l'intention de créer un système de
réservation où tous seront égaux
il y aura des espaces réservés pour les
contribuables de la municipalité qui a
mis en place l'infrastructure mais aussi
un certain nombre d' espaces réservés
pour l'ensemble des québécois qui
souhaitent accéder le plan d'eau avec
son collègue responsable de la faune
le ministre moreau travaille à mettre ce
système de réservation un service dès la
prochaine saison pêche tr craig radio
canada montréal